Madam President,
dear colleague.
This federal government seems fervently determined to finally end the times
when our country was respected and perhaps even envied internationally
for its strong industry,
its successful middle class,
its inventions,
its well-educated workers,
and its restrained foreign policy.
Instead of answering,
they operate on the citizen excuses and instead of concepts nicely colored.
We heard that in detail earlier,
especially in the's speech.
And if they do,
if they reap anger and indignation for it,
then they take to the streets and demonstrateally against
the results of their own policies.
They should rather ask themselves what their responsibility is to ensure
that the AfD has doubled and is becoming stronger and stronger.
Yes, we live,
we live in a time of wars,
and we live in a time of crisis.
And yet the economy is growing in other countries.
Energy is affordable,
apartments are built,
pensioners can live reasonably on their pensions,
migration is lower,
and at school children even learn to calculate and write relatively correctly.
It is not the world's fault,
but its failure,
that everything in Germany today is different.
Gas currently costs 1/4 of what companies pay in Germany in the U.S.
And both are now ensuring by cutting export capacity that
this price differential will continue in the future.
Electricity is more expensive in our country than Anders.
Where,
and they are authorizing a hefty revenue increase
on top of that for network operators.
Refueling and heating is hardly affordable for many.
You will worry about higher CO 2 prices and
VAT increases for the next price boost.
After all,
all of this is absolutely inconsiderate and would be on.
While other countries withdraw from financing the Ukrainian war,
Germany now pays more than half of all arms supplies from Europe.
And when it comes to Mr.
Merz and the weapons of enthusiastic Green and Liberal ones,
we will soon even supply taurus missiles,
with which Silenzki can then attack Moscow,
putting our own country in great danger.
What 1 madness more and more weapons for an unwinnable war.
But cuts in pensions,
in health and education as aloof,
as indifferent to the concerns of ordinary citizens must be
politicians who make such decisions.
Lower energy prices before it's too late by buying
raw materials back where they are cheapest.
Just as other countries are doing.
Take care of more teachers,
higher löne and real opportunities for advancement again,
instead of further expropriating the hardworking ones and then complaining about
shortages of skilled workers and lack of work motivation.
The mirror can now see her cabinet at jungle camp level.
Please come to the end,
I'll be over in a minute.
Citizens would be happy if the ampelspuk lasted even a few more days and
if they also had the power to choose out the worst loser every day.
Thank you very much.